I'm Leslie because jr. and this is my
story why do I like to paint well its
form of therapy in one respect this is
my art studio today here's some of my
brushes what do you see out there well
this is what I see I don't see gloom
doom I like to remember in my youth just
drawing pictures capturing the things
that I think are beautiful my mother I
know artistic talents used to paint in
oils and stuff so I guess some of that
interest got to me my parents were
separated when I was seven so I didn't
have them to rely on I spent the next 10
years in an orphans home my mother
couldn't handle it anymore five kids
left alone
and my father going like separation in
my early life made it more important to
have somebody care about me my my
brothers and sisters and how that
affected us most of the guys I knew were
all ready to go knock the trottin
there's a chance - I gotta go to
somewhere do something I was still a
loner because I know that when I came in
they didn't look at me it was too
confident that he's gonna mount anything
to get into that Brotherhood you had to
prove yourself worse
Richard Vargas was a tent mate and when
we were in England one of the things
that I admired about Richard was every
night he would kneel down beside his
caught and say the Rosary
this is the real thing now
no more maneuvers in play this is it
[Music]
we were pretty safe there for a moment
but then as the things quieted down like
it here
Vargas crying and whimpering him
Michelle had landed right beside him his
head was at my shoulder when I put this
tourniquet around him and I could see
his like shredded I said I knew I
couldn't cope with that
when I found out that he had died
I just went across the road and I just
sat on her Road and cried it out it
sounds so callous but there was much you
can do it's always been with me there is
no real freedom in these things we're
all obligated to something or somebody
in Holland they were in a day after day
and today can be helped
all the sudden them in Belgium I felt
this hot sensation in my hand and I knew
I had been hit they named it a
million-dollar wound a light wound it
would get him out of a front and
situation and to this day I'm still
carrying about a 3/8 inch piece of
shrapnel on my left brush which makes it
hard to operate there was no family who
come back to I was just looking for a
place to hang up my hat and I came back
to Philadelphia because that's where I
had grown up I was able to spend four
years at the University of Pennsylvania
studying architecture well that was my
career I worked as an architect for I
guess about 60 years I attended the
church and by up the street which was
Shelton Avenue Methodist Church and I
met Charlie and year later we would
become married and when her mother died
we decided that we would look for
another home a short time after that and
we have lived here ever since for 62
years
the fact that I was placed in an
orphanage made it more important to have
a family and to make the family function
the way it should function and I think
we achieved that the question was asked
to me what I think about my country and
what it means to be free I think you
know an American citizen should be
basically a responsible person to his
family first to his community and then
to his country the National warplane
museum in Geneseo New York has a
airplane up there called w7 whisky 7 and
it is the same plane that I jumped out
of one d-day we were fortunate enough to
have a number of our grandchildren and
great-grandchildren be there dear shall
we participate with us and actually get
a ride in the same plane that their
grandfather rode in
[Music]
what do you see out there this is what I
see I don't see going doom and this is
your Garden of Eden this is what we were
supposed to have
[Music]
and it's been a good life you just buy
the Borla term wa how can you be 92
years old does not be blessed those are
of course emotional statements and
they're always hard to stay and when you
have 13 great-grandchildren you have to
know that you were blessed by God and I
am
[Music]
you
you
[Music]